شكرا جزيلا سؤالان مهما فيما يخص
الجزء الاول لقد حصلنا على رد من ايران
وهو رد معقول لذلك قلنا اننا سوف
نرد على هذا الجزء من المساله التي هي
اوسع وسوف نحافظ
على تقييم
لهذا الموقع حيث اجريت
اختبارات او تجارب محدده لم نغير التقييم
انما حصلنا على رد معقول
ولا يمكننا ان نفترض ان ما قالوه قد حصل
وليس لدينا اي ادله لنبرهن ان هذا هي
الحال او ليست هي الحال ولكن
لا يمكن ان نستثني ذلك فيما يخص
الاراء والتعليقات حول ما نفعل نحن
معتادين على ذلك
يوما في يوم ما يكون هذا الطرف يقول ذاك
وفي اليوم التالي الطرف الاخر يقول ذلك
عملنا حياتي وسنقول دائما الامور مثل ما
هي
ليس نحن من ياخذ في الاعتراض في الاعتبار
ما راي الحكومات ما يمكن ان اقول هو ان
عملنا فني ما نقوله صحيح فنيا فيما يخص
نسبه 60% حول رده الفعل
ولماذا ليس هناك ردات فعل اكثر مشددا
السؤال ربما ينبغي ان يوجه الى اخرين ليس
لي ما نقوله هو اننا نخبر الاسره الدوليه
النسبه نسبه التخصيب وهي ستين بالمئه
مثلما ذكرتي
اكثر من 100 كلغ مئه 1615
كميه اليورانيوم المخصب تزداد
بنسب مختلفه من التخصيب
في ما ياخذون نسبه 60% تسالين هل قبلنا
تخصيب اليورانيوم ليس ممنوعا او محظورا
كما تعرفين ما نفعله هو اننا نتحقق مما
يحصل ونبلغ هذه اجابته
اعود الى ما اعتدنا ان نسمعه هو عدم رضا
من اسرائيل حول مسائل كثيره مرتبطه بهذا
الملف ولكن هناك اتهام شديد هنا هو
انكم خفضتم معايير الضمانات لاسباب سياسيه
هل يمكنك ان ترفض ذلك او تقول انه ليس
صحيحا
وفيما يخص تصريحكم للمجلس مجلس المحاطين
فيما يخص قبول ايران
بوضعي معدات المراقبه مع
الذي سبب ذلك لماذا تتاخر المساله وما متى
نتوقع ان ينجز ذلك فيما يخص المعايير
بالتاكيد
لم نخفف معاييرنا ابدا ابدا ابدا نحن
ملتزمون
بمعاييرنا نطبق المعايير
وفي هذه العمليه التي هي عمليه معقده
تتابعونها
كنا
صارمين
غير منحازين فنيا
وكنا حازمينا
عاتلين بل وحاسمين نحن لا نخفف من
المعايير لاسباب سياسيه انها امور متعلقه
بمواقف نتفهم ان يكون هناك مواقف ولكننا
لا ننحاز
هناك اراء مختلفه
اصدرنا بيانا مشتركا في شهر مارس
يفترض اننا سنطبق عددا
من اجراءات التحقق والرصد التوعيه ولكن
المساله تسير ببطء
هذا جزء من واجبي ينبغي ان ابلغ بالكامل
عما يحصل يمكن ان اقول لم يحصل شيئا فذلك
ليس بالصحيح الواقع هو اننا ركبنا بعض
الكاميرات
وركبنا اجهزه
تحقق رصد الكترونيه في اماكن معينه ولكن
ينبغي ان لا ونحقق المزيد
بما انني اريد ان يكون لدي ال قدرات
الاكبر للرفض في اسرع وقت ممكن
ربما بالاشاره الى ما سالت زميلتك ينبغي
ان نكون موجودين ان نرصد قدر الامكان لذلك
اقول ينبغي ان تسير الامور بسرعه اكبر
تؤالي متعلق باوكرانيا
سماع مجلس الامن اسبوع المنصرم اشرت الى
انكم تريدون مزيدا من الخبراء التابعينا
للوكاله في سفر في الوقت عينه اشارت الى
انها
سترفع عدد الاشخاص هناك كم هو عدد
الموجودين هناك وما هو العدد الذي تريده
في اطار النقاط الخمس احدها هو انه ينبغي
ان لا يكون هناك اي
عنصر عسكري قادر على
شني اي هجوم من هناك
شكرا جزيلا فيما يخص عدد الخبراء يختلف
في الاجمال لدينا اربعه اشخاص قد يكون
هناك عدد اكبر يعتمد ذلك على طبيعه العمل
التي ينبغي ان نطلع به نحن نرحب
تعليقي روسيا التي تسيطر على المحطه
ومفاده انه سيكون هناك تواجد اكبر
وايضا نقرر عدد الخبراء وفقا لطبيعه العمل
وفيما يخص المبادئ الخمسه التي ذكرتها
الاسبوع المنصرم
سوف نقيم ذلك على اساس الواقع
الهدف والمغزى مما نفعله هو اننا نعتبر ان
هناك عمل عمليات عسكريه او نشاط عسكري
وهناك
معلومات عن ذلك النشاط العسكري سيزداد في
المنطقه
وقد يكون هناك حاجه لمزيد من المراقبه
حول قدره خبرائنا على الرست انا متمسك بما
قلته في نيويورك
خبراءنا قادرين
على الرصد
والابلاغ عن المسائل
المذكوره في هذه المبادئ الخمس
لا سيما فيما يخص التواجد العسكري كنا
حذرين في صياغه
ذلك وفي الاستشارات لاننا
تشاورنا مع الطرفين فيما يخص هذه المبادئ
ووصف فيها على انها قادره على
ممارسه القوه بمقابل
الامن
فيما يخص
خطط اليابان
[موسيقى]
بالتخلص من مياه الملوثه هل من تحديثات
ومخاوف المخاوف تعرفونها هنا تدول في
المنطقه عبرت عن مخاوفها من هذه الخطه
ونحن
نستعد بدقه
نحضر تقارير وتقرير اذا كان هذا جانبا من
المؤتمر الصحفي الذي يعقده رافاييل روسيا
المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه لطاقه
الذريه بشان برنامج ايران النووي وتقدما
يقول انه احرز فيما يتعلق
بمراقبه منشات ايران وقد اعلن اجروسي ان
كميه مخزون ايران من اليورانيوم ارتفعت
خلال الاشهر الثلاثه الماضيه بمستويات
تخصيب مختلفه وتطرق ايضا الى الوضع في
محطه زبوروجيا في اوكرانيا وملفات